hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
questions about a friendship that is
raised in Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
book eight and also by implication in
other parts of his worse is whether a
bad person can actually be a friend or
not in alongside this we can also ask
whether bad people can be friends with
each other or whether they can only be
friends with good people or perhaps well
needed only good people are at least
neutral people can be friends with each
other and he resembles answer is one of
his typical yes and no kind of the
answer is depending on what sentence
were understanding friendship in this is
one reason why it is distinction between
the three main types of equal friendship
is so particularly important remember
that the friendships in terms of virtue
are based on virtue based on the good
where we actually feel affection towards
the other person and they towards us on
the basis of our personalities of
characters something actually attractive
within them rather than something that's
merely apparently attractive for a while
or the
lack of even that that is the highest
form of friendship and then is actually
not available for the bat for reasons
that will talk about friendships with
pleasure and friendships based on
usefulness Aristotle says that bad
people can be members in those sorts of
friendships or relationships but there's
going to be certain constraints even on
those as we'll see unequal friendships I
think there's some room in there
although aerosol doesn't discuss this
explicitly but there is some room in
there for bad people to be one of the
partners in an unequal friendship
obviously they're probably going to be
the person whose circle on the bottom in
the unequal friendship and then family
relations you know relations to
relatives even the sort of you know
family connections that the Greeks
called Xenia which we'll talk about in
another video all of that it's possible
for bad people but it's not possible in
the fullest or best extent so let's
let's start by looking at each of these
in turn and then we'll come to some main
other issues that the aerosol is going
to raise so firm ships with virtue is it
possible to have a friendship of virtue
if you don't have any virtue it's kind
of a no-brainer there no it's not
possible by definition for a bad person
and the word that aerosol tends to use
in this discussion is mo minerals which
can mean a weak person it can also mean
a vicious person because most area is a
term that he uses as a synonym for vice
for coquina and it's also a synonym for
for other kegs of weaknesses as Daniel
right so friendships of virtue is just
not going to be a feasible thing is now
that's not to say a bad person couldn't
desire a friendship a virtue or try to
pretend that they have something like
that but it's not really going to be
such and the more that you get to
the bad person the last year actually
going to like spending time with and
actually spending you know getting to
know who they are you don't really want
to know who they are you might actually
be happier with the initial illusion
this happens quite often in romantic or
erotic relationships where somebody gets
involved with somebody else who's very
manipulative who is you know lying to
the other person lying perhaps to
themselves about the kind of person that
they actually are and then treats them
badly as a result or treats other people
badly and then it has to cover that up
somewhere eventually it's great fall
apart the long and short of it there
never really was a friendship in terms
of virtue or friendship in terms of the
good in such a case what about
friendships of pleasure sure it's it's
entirely possible to be a bad person and
also to be able to give pleasure to
other people in some ways so you could
have somebody who you enjoyed dining
with you enjoy you know the pleasures of
the table as we say of drinking and
heating but they're not a good person as
a matter of fact perhaps or even a bad
person it may detract from your pleasure
to a certain degrees especially if you
are well put together seeing somebody
stiff somebody else on the tip would be
a prime example out of greediness you
know are stingy us but it is possible
they have friendships of pleasure with
bad people and we'll talk a little bit
more about that in a moment friendships
of usefulness is it possible to have
these more widespread more common less
effective less close relationships where
we're not in it because we really like
the person for who they are or because
we find that person's company Pleasant
or we enjoy Pleasant things in their
company but rather we get something out
of it they are good for our social
status they connect us with other people
they are business partners they're
friends of the family who were just we
just happen to be connected with
we can go on and on and on with these
sorts of things it's certainly possible
for a bad person to have friendships of
usefulness as a matter of fact Aristotle
seems to hint at one point that if all
you have our friendships of usefulness
you're probably a bad person you're
probably badly off with respect to that
because oh no people don't find YouTube
lessons and nobody likes you for who you
are so this is all you've got going for
you then there is there's probably a
moral problem there unequal friendships
like I said Aristotle does not talk
about somebody who is actively bad in
terms of unequal friendships he talks
more in terms of people who are bringing
something to the table and can say
recognize the virtue of the really good
person but haven't made it that far
themselves it's unlikely that the
actively bad person is going to have a
unequal friendship with the virtuous
unless the virtuous him or herself
decides to you know take the bad person
under their wing try to fix things for
them and then one of the few things is
likely to happen either the bad person
is going to stay bad and eventually the
virtuous person is probably gonna have
to cut loose you know at least from an
Aristotelian point of view or the the
bad person will have actually become
attracted towards what it is that the
virtuous person has to offer and want to
change their own life and that it's no
longer a relationship with a bad person
now is it family relatives you know as
the old saying goes you can pick your
friends but you can't pick your family
we're born into these sorts of relations
a bad person can certainly live within
these Aristotle actually has an example
in another book about a man who beats
his father and drags his father out of
the house up to a certain point I
remembered
where it is in the yard and when the man
is criticized for that he says look I'm
not going too far because my father
dragged his father exactly this far so
that's okay for me that's an example of
a dysfunctional family right there right
and Aaron's level would say you can have
all sorts of dysfunctional families
dysfunctional families from a moral
point of view are dysfunctional not just
because of some dynamic that they have
no control over it's also because of the
bad character of the people within the
relationship which could in fact be
changed change their relation to the
person's you'll eventually will start to
change their relationship not overnight
but you know certainly you can make some
headway into it now there's a few things
to say here as well Arizona thinks that
ban people can be involved in chrome
ships but the friendships that they have
are now typically long-lasting why not
well you know the friendships that would
be the longest lasting friendships in
terms of virtue is simply not available
for them for instance of pleasure and
friendships of usefulness are shorter
duration they last so long as the the
parties are getting out of the
relationship what it is that they're
looking for so when people cease having
pleasuring each other's company or cease
getting pleasure from each other then
that friendship is going to break up
when friends are no longer useful to
each other but perhaps even the opposite
become harmful to each other then the
friendship will break up the
relationship will break up unless of
course it becomes you know what you know
some sort of dysfunctional relationship
in which case it may continue is
probably going to make people worse
right so bad people don't make good
friends for very long because in
friendships of pleasure they're
typically thinking about what can I get
out of this and they're less
interested in whether they're actually
giving pleasure to the other person the
proverbial selfish lover in terms of
erotic would be a great example of this
you know make sure that you get what you
want out of it but the other person they
can figure it out for themselves you're
not going to see their relationship
varied along with anybody who has
something on the ball if that's what's
going up same thing we can say with
other matters as well and when it comes
to the friendships of usefulness if you
actually start to become you know
harmful as we sometimes say toxic right
to your friends your friends the ones
who have a sample to have some good sets
they're going to cut you loose and when
it comes to business relationships which
are what a lot of friendships of
usefulness turn out to be or you know
other types of relationships would fit
that as well people will give you the
cold shoulder they able to cut you off
if you display some sort of moral
badness particularly if its moral
badness that affects them have so much
other people now another thing that he
says is that damn people can actually
take pleasure in each other's badness on
the terminal it uses there again it
smoke theory it could be interested
again it's weakness or as viciousness
let's just keep the category of general
badness bad people might actually be in
a friendship of pleasure because they
both love pulling the wings off flies
right or are they both enjoyed bullying
other people now how stable is that
going to be it really depends you know
with bullying bullies turn out each
other when they're no longer allowed to
bully then perhaps they split up think
about intro leurs and their communities
you know as an example of that they take
pleasure in each other's badness they
don't take pleasure in each other's
goodness or in the sorts of things that
other people usually take pleasure in
and this is also going to be
somewhat short lived as well there's
some inherent problems with it but it is
you know something that we can also say
about the vicious person in relation to
him or herself part of what makes
ambitious is taking pleasure in the
wrong sorts of things so when you put
vicious people together they take
pleasure together in the wrong sorts of
things that other people are looking in
from the outside then you get messed up
you guys are you guys are scripts don't
let them hear you're my kids or other
people that I care about so you know it
they answer the question it is indeed
possible for bad people to have
friendships but by virtue of being bad
people they are cut off from as we go up
the scale from what is actually involved
in friendships they can't be friends in
terms of who they really are which is a
real deprivation that they may feel but
but you know that could motivate them to
quit being mad people eventually they
friendships aren't lasting they're more
prone to arguments and disputes so they
don't really enjoy friendship at any
full sense although they enjoy what we
might call friendship by analogy